[Music]
you know you're here you can come out
what do you want Clark it's like this
Bruce sooner or later somebody's gonna
ask me to bring you in
someone with for when that happens that
happens the best man
Bruce
I think it's time we put our differences
aside and work together what I mean why
you're Batman yeah did I have no special
powers I basically just [ __ ] yes
kitchenettes Bruce your scientific mind
along he's completely useless let me
have a man get bullets they really bound
Jaffa your fighting skills my main
nemesis is Bane basically just a
roided-out jock with a gas mask and he
straight-up broke my back you could have
taken him down with one hand and with
the other head you could have just
jerked you did it here super jerk it's
just I don't
okay I get it
you're having an image problem don't be
ridiculous
I'm Superman yeah exactly it's [ __ ]
white bread with boring look at you and
your stupid outfit my father gave me
this outfit but your dad is dead get
over your dead parents already didn't
your parents die sorry bye dude is cool
cuz I made myself daddy's boy you got a
stupid S on your chest case we could
forget who you are it's my peoples
symbol for hope Oh starts with an H
stupid okay okay stop Haitian you're
late
you're wearing eye makeup [ __ ] you I
need you to parrot my abilities from a
different [ __ ] atmosphere this year
makes me strong
you [ __ ] nerd with your nerd hair
Superman I saw the bad signal what's
going on Commissioner Gordon Batman and
I were discussing a partnership with
what did I say yeah it seems completely
unnecessary
hey I've been dealing with you lunatics
for about a decade
and this is I can't believe it I'm gonna
say this I'm in total agreement with
Batman feels good
why are you guys being this way
somebody's got to tell you man you're
boring really even your alter-ego I mean
I picked like 1970s Hugh Hefner you
picked like a what are the Newsies yeah
what is it
I didn't base my alter ego off of the
musical Newsies which beauty did you
bathe Clark Kent our pet yg crutchy
I'm not clutching his dog feeling that
it was crunchy I'm not clutching and I
prefer if we didn't discuss my alter ego
around the commissioner
take it easy crutchy I know that you're
Clark Kent what um
news flash it takes a little more than
wearing a hat and or glasses to fool
people Billy
check this out watch uh-oh I'm someone
else I get fooled
I'm not Commissioner Gordon he's gone
who are you where's kitty here good oh
you're back
Commissioner no someone else Superman
you sobs there was another babe he's
hiding in the shadows the man's gone you
know what screw you guys just just
forget it
yeah all this lameness might be one of
the reasons why you've never been able
to seal the deal with Lois Lane leave
her she's always just throwing that
brassy sassy news reporter pooed in your
face hey this just in put this just
kidding me
stop it's the point of being the Man of
Steel if you don't know how to use all
that metal in yes
you're adorable Lina did sweetie
burnish with your magic eyes epiha first
boys use it for something lame like
cutting through a nice burger he kept an
old woman's porridge is yet soup too
cold madam I'd use that you have to take
off things are stop it
I came here to team up not to be berated
because guess what I'm doing under the
Cape use your x-ray vision
I'll save you the trouble I'm giving you
the bird
what's this beam on Krypton gratitude
how goodbye one sec yeah the letter H is
also the symbol for help on my planet
I'm glad there kid where's the good oh
you're back and I hate you again yeah
I'm confused easily
[Music]